I spoke with Emperor Palpatine last night and he
assured me that the ISB will be taking the lead
going forward welcome back everyone it's Charlie
this will be my full Star Wars Andor episode 7
video there are a whole bunch of Easter eggs and
references so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel be sure to subscribe to
get all the episodes and careful for spoilers from
the episode if you haven't seen it yet we'll
just start at the beginning and work our way
through shot by shot talking about Easter eggs
and WTF moments a lot of you asking if Emperor
Palpatine was gonna cameo in this series because
we're dealing so much with the Imperial Senate on
Coruscant they mentioned him so many times in this
episode so it would be weird if he doesn't Cameo
at some point during the series starting with the
episode title which was announcement which is a
reference to dedra's term for what she calls The
Heist that Andor and the rebels just pulled off
stealing the payroll she says the rebels were
making an announcement so to speak about their
intent to fight the Empire and form an official
Rebellion but the actual opening scene was of
Cyril Karn at his mother's house getting another
lecture about advancing himself in society inside
the Empire getting ready for this interview with
the Empire's Bureau of Standards thank you very
much Uncle Harlow I wonder if we're ever going to
meet Uncle Harlow because they referenced him so
much during all these Karn scenes with his mother
he learns about the rebels Heist on aldhani and
then the gears are already turning in his head and
by the end of the episode he still hasn't followed
up on his pursuit of them but I think the idea is
that his job will just become so soul-crushing for
him like that's the whole idea his new job in that
sad looking soul-crushing cubicle I think is meant
to drive him to pull another ferrix go rogue and
do what Dedra just did like overreach so to speak
but in pursuit of this Rebellion bringing him
back to the main plot because right now he's on
the fringes of the story like he's not pursuing
andor actively and I think the whole idea here
is he's like a Les Mis Javert type of character
who just won't give up like something will clue
him into what's happening with the rebellion
and he'll link it to Andor and pharynx and
I'll use that to renew his pursuit of what's
going on also the Bureau of Standards where he
goes to interview kind of reminds me of the TVA
inside the Loki series like you become this Cog
in this giant machine obviously in the Star Wars
Universe we're talking about a cog in the giant
machine that is the Empire which crushes you down
to nothingness metaphorically and litter early we
see dedra changing her white Imperial Security
Bureau uniform we haven't seen a whole lot of
the Empire just casually changing their uniforms
like this the meaning that they're having is a big
deal because we meet Colonel Yularen who's a huge
character from the Canon he was a big character on
Star Wars the Clone Wars Star Wars Rebels and some
of the grand Admiral Thrawn tie-in books I believe
Dave Filoni introduced him during the Clone Wars
series for the first time what ended up happening
later though is that he was stationed on the
first Death Star when Luke Skywalker destroyed
it so he died during that explosion so he's not
around during the time of the Mandalorian after
Return of the Jedi in the context of this meeting
he's meant to be partagas's supervisor like he's
One Step Above him in rank and he makes all these
references to the Empire closing its fist which
is a callback to Princess Leia's quote talking
to Tarkin also in A New Hope even though that's
happening in the future of the timeline like
they'll pay it off during a New Hope later the
more you you tighten your grip tuck the more star
systems will slip through your finger a couple
characters actually make references to things like
this during the episode you Lauren's whole plan to
increase taxation around the Empire increase
Imperial measures increase their Authority is
going to backfire and it's only going to help the
rebels cause like more of the Galaxy will begin
to support them also you can make a prequels
joke when he talks about increasing Taxation
and it being a callback to Phantom Menace with
a huge plot point because the Trade Federation
was increasing taxation of trade routes at the
beginning of that movie he's also the first person
in the episode to mention Emperor Palpatine there
are several characters that reference Palpatine
during the episode saying that the emperor has
increased the authority of the ISB within the
Empire's military basically using the Senate to
pass all this legislation to make it easier for
them to have more Authority and they're using that
to basically strip away people's freedoms which is
exactly what the emperor did during the prequels
like during attack of the Clones the Clone Wars
Revenge of the Sith you kept seeing past this new
legislation just to make it easier and easier for
him to strip away democracy and turn the Republic
into the empire into more of an autocracy
manmathma Bale Organa Padme were all good examples
of people in the Senate who saw what he was doing
and realized the whole time and fought against
it but most of the Senate were either already
loyal to him too lazy to care or were fooled by
him until it was too late he says the first part
of this new legislation the emperor's passing is
called the public order sentencing directive and
they talk about it being this big meeting that
the Senate is having soon which hasn't happened
yet like my mouth says we're getting ready
to have the meeting so there'll be a bunch
more scenes inside the actual Senate maybe that's
what we get our Emperor Palpatine Cameo scene they
also said at the end of the episode with Andor
being arrested and sentenced to six years for
just looking suspicious like he didn't do anything
that's the whole joke like I was just walking here
looking around at the scenery trying to figure
out what's happening that's going to get you six
years in prison right there buddy just looking
weird all because of the aftermath of the rebels
heist in the increased measures that the Empire is
taking some of you made the connection to when the
judge makes the joke about taking up with the
emperor the whole 6 Year's reference is meant
to be a reference to the Battle of Yavin basically
like they'll destroy the first death star and that
will be them taking it up with the emperor it'll
just take a couple years for them to pay that off
but as I mentioned earlier one of the reasons why
deadra isn't happy about the Empire's reactionary
measures is because she correctly guesses that it
will backfire and the Galaxy will begin to favor
the Rebellion even more like a lot of characters
realize this even luhten later says I knew this
would happen and I wanted it to happen because
even though there'll be a lot of collateral
damage the Empire is going to crack down and start
killing a lot of innocent people that will only
drive the Galaxy further towards the Rebellion it
will only help our cause it's also meant to show
you how hardcore some of the rebels are like it
wasn't like they won the Galaxy back with a polite
conversation with the emperor she also makes
another direct reference to them being Rebels
she's one of the First characters to actually
use that term Rebels to describe them later in
the episode when Marvaa makes the reference to
Rebellion I believe she's also one of the first
characters to mention that term too to actually
call it a rebellion back with luthen we get this
huge Ahsoka Tano easter egg too some of you may
have realized this so when he's listening on his
comlink there's this really robotic sounding voice
it's someone hiding their voice but it's the way
that they communicate between Rebel cells that's
basically what Ahsoka did during the Rebellion
she went under the code name fulcrum and served as
the point of communication between different Rebel
cells so the voice that he's actually listening
to on the com here would be ahsoka's voice just
relaying information from other rebel cells I
don't know if they have any kind of planned Ahsoka
Tano Cameo scene or anything like that because
most of the rebels didn't learn that she was
actually the fulcrum character till the events of
Star Wars Rebels which happens a little bit after
this in the timeline also connection to what was
happening with the Yularen character during Star
Wars Rebels when they get into that whole Ahsoka
fulcrum storyline you learn as also part of Star
Wars Rebels in a big way mostly through the thrawn
character like that's the big connection to Ahsoka
so him being a big character during this series
just makes it sound like there's some Ahsoka stuff
going on in the background too because we're in
luthen's shop and his shop is littered with easter
eggs from all the different Star Wars movies
Series in the Canon and I think these blasters
were featured during the original trilogy but I
can't remember exactly where they come from if you
think you know where they come from specifically
write them below in the comments then when mon
mothma shows up to talk about the actual heist
we learned later that her driver Kloris really
is a spy for the ISB like a lot of people wondered
that is he a plant yep turns out he is the funny
thing about that is we actually find out the
reason why the ISB put a plant to spy on her
is because of all of her charitable organizations
just the regular ones like they don't know that
she's part of the Rebellion they don't think that
she's doing anything suspicious with that they're
just watching her because she just has regular
charities like how dare you try to help people
even though later she develops this long-term plan
for the Rebellion which I'll talk about when we
get to that part of the episode when she starts
talking to luthen she mentions he's been using
her own personal family funds up to this point to
support the Rebellion but that's been a pittance
compared to the 80 million credits that they just
stole from the payroll and the whole idea is they
need this giant pile of money to really push the
Rebellion to coalesce into the formal Rebellion
that you think of when you think of the rebels
from the original trilogy like up to this point
they just been this disparate pocket of a bunch
of different resistance cells but with all this
money now they can coalesce into something much
more organized you also look around his shop it
seems like they've moved a lot of the Easter eggs
around too there are a couple of new ones that we
didn't see in the previous episodes I'm not sure
where these giant clawed gauntlets are from but
they seem familiar if you think you know right
below in the comments right in front of them is
placoon's mask from the prequels he was killed
during Order 66 in Revenge of the Sith I've
already talked about the Starkiller armor in the
background that hasn't really changed position but
the other real big Easter egg probably the biggest
one in this episode next to all the Palpatine and
the Ahsoka stuff is the Jedi Temple Guardian armor
in the background if you didn't watch Star Wars
Rebels or Obi-Wan Kenobi you didn't realize the
grand Inquisitor actually used to be one of the
temple Guardians at the Jedi Temple on Coruscant
before he fell to the dark side supported the
emperor and became the grand Inquisitor I don't
know if this is his armor specifically it could
be she references Emperor Palpatine for the second
time saying that their big meeting were he's going
to pass all this legislation is happening soon
like in a future episode and then when claya
comments about whether or not my mothma is going
to be worth the trouble obviously we know she is
because she becomes one of the de facto leaders
in public faces of the Rebellion it just seems
like she needs that push to fully commit maybe
it's going to wind up being the death of her
family you can post all your theories about that
in the comments below like what is going to cause
her to fully commit to the Rebellion then during
Karen's actual interview at the Imperial Bureau
of Standards he tries to play his firing like
the Empire is being too LAX and use it as an
example of what a dedicated worker is going to
be but clearly his supervisor doesn't want to
have anything to do with that like you know what
let's just scrub some of this bad stuff off of
your record probably do some good we get a literal
little Cameo from the mouse droid first seen on
the Death Star during a new hope his new job and
fuel Purity is literally just in checking on the
purity of the fuel that sold to the Empire that
they use in all their ships like in all the naval
ships and even though they do this throughout
the entire episode all over the place on all
these different planets at the Depot station you
notice the officer wearing helmet that looks just
like the helmets worn by Rebel officers during a
new hope you probably noticed a lot of costumes
the characters are wearing that seem similar to
costumes from the original trilogy. Kleya winds
up having this clandestine meeting with vel
sartha who's got this big glow up since The
Big Heist episode who they basically task with
finding in either a killing andor bringing him
into the Rebellion they imply kill like you need
to do something about him but because of what
happens to him during the episode getting arrested
getting the six-year sentence obviously they'll
use it as an opportunity to bring him formally
into the Rebellion like it's either us or go to
prison for the next six years jokes on all them
because he's gonna die way before six years then
the black Droid here when deirdre's trying to
get these records isn't k2so is just meant to
foreshadow the KX Droids that we actually do see
at the end of the episode k2so references because
if you notice the Droid is manning this archive
that's very similar to the archive inside the
Imperial facility that k2so was helping andor
get into at the end of Rogue one I don't know
if we're actually going to get a real k2so Cameo
scene because obviously the droids are the end
or just regular KX droids it's not k2so because
it's not Alan tudik doing the voice maybe during
season two then at mod mothma's party we meet
take Colma who's just another powerful person
from chandrilla her home planet she says that his
family owns this giant Bank of Colma so it sounds
like he's super rich too just like she is it seems
like they've been friends ever since they were
very little kids and they pay off the reference
she made earlier to Luthen saying that she knew
someone that she wanted to bring in to the circle
so to speak like this powerful person that she
thought that could help them using his Banks to
move all the rebels money she also mentions the
separatists from the prequels when she's talking
to him too she says that she fights and often
fails to protect separatist do-gooders I think
what that means is that during the prequels for
instance she was opposed to the war with the
separatists because of the collateral damage
it would cause the entire galaxy so it's her
referencing her auntie Palpatine stance because
everything with the clone wars were his big thing
like he pushed for the actual Clone Wars to happen
and it was him just manipulating events in
the galaxy to push through all this Shady
legislation to formally create the Empire she also
references Emperor Palpatine literally again for
the third time when she says that she learned
from his skill and deception hiding his true
intentions and I don't think that he's faking any
of his hatred of the Empire to I think he's just
trying to let us know that oh yeah he's totally
down what she's talking about like I will totally
help you out we get our Andor Bix reunion they
also confirmed that they used to be a thing a
long time ago like an on-again off-again kind
of relationship even though she explains to him
that he needs to get off of ferrics like he's
Enemy Number One all the citizens hate him now
because the Empire's Crackdown is because of what
he did we're not done with ferrics like they just
gave Dedra control of ferric so she's coming to
Ferris to start investigating what's going on
with the rebels so even though he takes off at
the end of the episode obviously he'll probably
come back at some point also him paying off all
of his existing debts to the other people that
he knew on the planet in the town is just a way
of showing that he's not a total Dirtbag like
he's not running out on all of his debts then
we get a huge WTF flashback scene seeing how
his father was was killed by the clone troopers
and those are clone troopers because remember
that was taking place closer to the events of the
prequels before they completely transitioned to
their regular stormtrooper armor basically what
they explained is that his father was trying to
stop some other dissidents and the Empire confused
him for one of the dissidents so you're throwing
rocks at us well we're gonna kill you now which
is basically what happens to Andor like he gets
in trouble for literally not doing anything at all
like he just happens to be near a lot of trouble
that was happening and they just confused him for
one of the other dissidents getting hauled in just
like your father how ironic his whole conversation
with his mother about not running embracing the
idea of the Rebellion isn't referencing the same
Rebellion that loosen is forming it's just meant
to reference the concept of standing up to the
Empire like rebelling against their Authority in
general not the actual formal Rebellion also when
she says what's happening here on this plan on
pharynx is happening everywhere in the Galaxy you
can't run anywhere it'll be the same everywhere
you go which is meant to foreshadow the end of the
episode when that literally happens like he goes
to a pleasure Planet some vacation plan at some
distant place and it still winds up happening
to him they referenced his sister again we haven't
really followed up with the sister plot in a while
what will probably happen early prediction is that
he will eventually find out what happened to her
in my other early WTF twist prediction will be
that she'll also be part of the Empire like all
the children here that were part of his tribe that
got captured by the empire were taken and inducted
to the Empire so she might be on the other side
of this conflict so to speak and they might get
into that during season two like I think there'll
be a big reveal towards the end of this season
about what happened to the sister and it will just
push into their season two plot inside the other
meeting they mention ORD Mandel they've used that
planet a bunch of times in the Star Wars TV shows
and movies it's one of the capital planets in the
midroom that the Empire is now using during this
part of the timeline is a big Naval Shipyard it
was also one of the homes of the black Sun crime
syndicate during Shadows of the Empire big Shadows
of the Empire deep cut they're the big standoff
between Dedra and blevin and she winds up getting
the upper hand because particast likes that she's
taking the initiative so much the funny thing
is that she's being rewarded for it and scarn
kind of did the same thing in wound up getting the
short end of the stick during the little standoff
here too they also referenced that partagas is
the person who came up with the way the Empire
organizes the Galaxy into different sectors so
just for reference a sector contains many systems
like many systems of planets moths are typically
meant to be the governors of entire sectors Grand
mafs like Grandma Tarkin were the governors of
what they called over sectors which contained
several sectors at the height of the Empire there
were over 20 moths in just a couple Grand mafs so
Grandma Tarkin wasn't the only Grand Moff then on
the Nemo's vacation plan Andorra gets the payoff
of Marvel's comment about the Empire cracking
down everywhere like you can't run whatever is
happening here is going to be happening wherever
you go and like I said it's another reference to
what happened to his father like his father was
mistakenly believed to be a dissident and hauled
in for it and the same thing happens to him like
the whole joke here is that he didn't even do
anything like he was just walking to the store
and the other criminals just happened to run by
him we also see the KX droids for the first time
in the series obviously just like k2so different
Droid case 2so because his voice by Alan tudik
we'll see if we see him during season two also
it seems like there's been a small time Jump too
because he's been going by a different name Keith
and he's been hooking up with this girl here and
it seems like he's known for a little while she
could be somebody they work with before or just
some random girl that he met at the bar here and
then the whole joke about sentencing him to six
years for literally doing nothing oh this used
to be a six-month sentence but uh some stuff
happened and the Empire passed a bunch of new
legislation the emperor just did something so now
it's six years like I said that's a reference to
the events of A New Hope in the destruction of
the first Death Star like yes we will take it up
with the emperor and I think what happens after
this is that Val sartha will eventually find out
where he is and help him escape and that'll be
his push to join the actual Rebellion like look
you either help us out or you go to prison for
six years in the end the episode with Scar and
back in his sad little cubicle like I said
he's wasting away here eventually something
will probably happen to clue him in on what's
happening on ferrix what was happening with
Andor and he'll try to use his job to get back in
on the actual action on the actual hunt for Andor
but if you spotted any other Easter eggs or
references in the episode that I didn't talk about
in the video just write them Below in the comments
like I said so many Emperor Palpatine mentions in
the episode it just seems like they're setting
up a cameo for him later in the series my full
Andor episode 8 video will post next week after
they release it and big reminder too next week
they're also going to be releasing Star Wars tales
of the Jedi episodes I'll probably do a giant
episode video for all the episodes will you wait
for everything everyone click here for my house of
the Dragon episode 10 video and click here for my
Mandalorian season 3 trailer video in Easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys in the next one!